es ist ein seltsamer ort das tal es
dahlen in norwegen nicht kugeln fliegen
dort seit jahrhunderten durch die luft
was hat es mit den mysteriösen
leuchterscheinungen auf sich jetzt in
clixoom science und fiction
keine frage dass hier sieht aus wie ein
ufo dieses video sorgte 2007 für große
aufregung könnte es sich um ein ufo
handeln ist das tal es darlehen in
norwegen ein landeplatz für
außerirdische es macht auf jeden fall
den anschein
und es gibt keinerlei logische erklärung
für das phänomen nur eins ist sicher es
gibt diese leuchte erscheinung und sie
sind nicht vom menschen gemacht und sie
tauchen nur ihr in diesem tal auf und
das ist schon ein riesen schritt im
vergleich zu anderen unerklärlichen
phänomen bei denen wissenschaftler
lieber die existenz des phänomens an
sich erst mal grundsätzlich in frage
stellen
diese lichtkugeln existieren wirklich
und sie verhalten sich höchst seltsam
manchmal sind es nur kleine flackernde
lichter sie pulsieren oder stehen
stundenlang am himmel
sie können groß wie ein auto sein oder
information fliegen sie sind weiß
bräunlich oder rötlich und in ihnen ist
manchmal eine struktur zu erkennen
sie bewegen sich langsam oder mit bis zu
30.000 kilometern pro stunde alles
höchst seltsam seit 200 jahren wird
dieses phänomen schon beobachtet und
hunderte menschen haben die leucht bälle
schon gesehen
inzwischen gibt es eine
beobachtungsstation und jeder der ins
internet kommt mit computer smartphone
tablet usw kann live ins tal sehen und
mit ein wenig glück selbst in echtzeit
die licht phänomene beobachten nur eins
ist unbefriedigend
niemand weiß was da zu sehen ist
allerdings weiß man schon ein wenig über
die leuchten sind über die eigenschaften
sie scheinen nicht heiß zu sein da wo
sie zum beispiel bäume berühren
verkohlen sie nichts kein blatt kein ast
ist verbrannt
allerdings gibt es an diesen stellen
wohl keine mikroben mehr wie beobachtet
wurde
es spricht einiges dafür dass es sich um
plasma handelt also einen
aggregatzustand der dem gasförmigen
zustand ähnlich ist beim plasma handelt
es sich um ein teilchen gemisch aus
ionen und elektronen
das würde auch erklären warum die hess
dahlen lichter oft während oder nach dem
auftreten von polarlichtern erscheinen
auch polarlichter bestehen aus plasma
das tat scheint wie eine batterie gebaut
zu sein
auf der einen seite ist das gestein
kupfer haltig und auf der anderen seite
enthält es überdurchschnittlich viel
zink und eisen
dazwischen fließt der fluss hesse aus
inzwischen geschlossenen bergwerken wird
schwefel in den fluss gespült fertig ist
eine batterie
allerdings gibt es noch keinerlei
beweise dass das wirklich die erklärung
für das phänomen ist noch gibt es nicht
die geringste erklärung wie plassmann
leuchtkugeln unter diesen bedingungen
also das in der natur genau die
substanzen sind die für eine batterie
notwendig sind entstehen könnten
es wird wohl noch eine weile ein großes
rätsel bleiben
gar nicht rätselhaft sondern verblüffend
krebs spontan bereit sich masern impfung
das letzte video hierbei klicks um den
link gibt es natürlich in der video
beschreibung wie auch den zu rap täglich
aktuelle news und eine menge mehr dafür
jetzt dort drüben klicken und mich
interessiert nur noch eins was meint ihr
sind die ersten lichter natürlich oder
über natürlich was ist eure erklärung
und jetzt würde ich sagen auf abonnieren
klicken ist er kostenlos also bis dann
bleibt dran